こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
あのー…
あのとてもありがたいことに
動画外の活動がすごく多いんですよ
てことで3月も色々な事をして、
あのー正直、
なかなか、休む時間がっ、
なかったんですよ
丸一日休みなんてまずねぇ
YouTuberないですからね！
そんな中私は3月かけ走った結果なんですけども
あの身体…がめちゃくちゃー…やばいことになってしまいました(；ω；)
あのまずは腕です
そっから見えるかはわかんないんすけど
これは前からだった気がするんですよね
腕の付け根がめちゃくちゃ…悪化しました
これだけだったら別に前と一緒だし
動画にする必要ないと思ったんですけども
さらにっ☆
追加で身体に異常が起きました☆
こちらっっっ！
商品紹介みたいになってますけど
結構…痛いんですよ、こっちは。
相当ボロボロになってるんですけど、ﾜｯ､わからづらいかなぁ？(’・ω・’)
どっちかっていうとこっちの方が酷いっすね
ここがもう…あのね…
痛いです(真顔)
ｗwｗ
自分じゃ見↑れん↑
自分じゃ見えんですけどどうですか？
脚のここもボロッボロなんですよね
なんなら出血とかしてるんですよ
あーこれだとわかりやすいかな
もう相当ボロボロっすね
身体がっボロボロですっ☆
で、なんでこれ動画にしようと思ったかと言いますと
なんかねー前だったら「痒い」で済んでたんですよ
「痒い」で済んでたんですけども
今回、
痛いんですよ
痛い。
歩いても痛いからね
なんかできればね、脚を曲げたくない
曲げるとこうピリピリして痛いし
寝てる時も無意識に掻いているみたいで
なんか血が出たりしちゃってて
前回病院に行った時聞いたのは、
”乾燥肌”が原因って言われたんですけども
さすがに乾燥肌で掻いて、痛みが出たり
こんなに悪化することってある？って思いまして
わかんないっす、何が原因かわからないんですけども
ちょっともう一回病院に行って
ちゃんと聞いてこようかと思います
みんなにも言われたんですけどぱっと見やっぱ
目に入っちゃうぐらいちょっと悪化してきたんで
さすがにこれ、映像に映る人間として
ちょっと治さなきゃと思いまして
ちょっとまだ、まだ忙しいんですけど
何とか今日時間があるみたいなんで
あの…病院に行ってきます
いってきます☆
[ｺﾞｰﾝ…(暗い鐘の音)]
ただいまでーす(テン下げ)
はい、というわけで帰って参りました
ちょっともう痛くて痒くてどうしようもなくて
すぐ薬はその場で塗ったんですけど
ちょっと白くなってるんですけど
薬は…塗らせて頂きました…
ここはもう...すｯ､やｯ､やばいな！もう！
なんか火傷…みたいになってんね
はい、というわけで
お医者さんと話した内容をまとめてみます
えっとですね、前行った時と
ちょっと話が変わってきまして
前行った時は本当にただの季節的な乾燥肌で
痒くなっちゃって掻きまくって
「こうなってるよ～、うん♪」
って言われたんですけども
今回ちょっと別のことを言われて
さすがに乾燥肌でこんな酷いことにはならない
って言われて
お医者さんの予想だと
多分”アトピー”もちょっとあるんじゃないか
という結果を頂きました
確かにね
普通に乾燥肌だけでこんな…
部分的じゃんね
乾燥肌って身体全体のことなのに
なんかこんなね
局所的になるのはおかしいんで
どうやらちょっとただの乾燥肌とは違うんじゃないかという話を頂きました
やー…やっぱ薬塗っても痒いもんは痒いですね
結構…ちなみに重症みたいです
「ここまで酷くなってるんか」
みたいな言われ方をしたんで
結構もう…や、やばい状態ですね
フッｗ
だって行く時間ねぇもん！！！！！
僕の中ではえっと最速で行きました
で、お薬をねーなんか
たくさん貰ってきたんですよねー
多分よく聞くやつなんですけどね
”ヒルドイド”ってやつを使うみたいですね、はい
…なんか色々使い方があるみたいなんですけど
よく聞きますね”ヒルドイド”って
ちなみにね…”おくすり手帳”も作ってもらいました♡
僕基本病院行きたくないんすよ
あんま好きじゃなくて、
行きたくないけども行かざるを得ない状況に
追い込まーれるってことは
相当なんですよ
まじで痒かった
痒すぎるのともう痛いので結構ね、
限界レベルだったんでェ
もし同じ症状とか痒かったり悩んでる人がいたら
まじすぐ行った方がいいと思います。
...でお薬がね、２つ貰いました
”油性クリーム”って書いてあるんすけど
まあ俗にみなさんがよく使ってる保湿クリームの
最強版みたいなもんです
おぉ...
これを薬剤師の人にも言われたんですけど
一日に何回…
使用容量ないらしいんで
もう何回も塗っちゃっていいらしいです
で、お医者さんに僕言われたんすよ
あの、
一応ですね
僕毎日保湿クリーム塗ってるんですよ
保湿クリームってね、
でも毎日塗ってりゃいいってもんじゃなくて
保湿クリームを塗るのが目的じゃなくて
保湿クリームを塗って、保湿できてるかどうかが
大事らしいです
今すごい重要なこと言いましたよ
どういうことかと言いますと
なんか人によってその、
肌が乾燥しやすいとかしにくいとかあるらしくて
で、僕はめちゃくちゃ乾燥しやすい方なんですよ
超乾燥肌。
なので人によっては1日1回の
保湿クリーム塗る量でいい人もいるし
乾燥しやすい人は、あの、
本当に酷い人は1日10回ぐらい
1日10回ぐらい保湿クリームを塗らなきゃいけない人もいるらしいんですよ
なのでね、僕がね1日1回保湿クリームを
つけたところで
実際は保湿はできてないみたかったです(？)
日常的に風呂上がりに塗っておけばいいやと
思ってたんですけども
それだと全然足んないみたいで
つーわけでこのクリームは本当、
隙あれば塗ってくれって言われたんで
僕しばらくベタベタしてます
よろしくお願いします。
もう塗りすぎでいいらしいっすね、本当に
肌を潤わせることが大事らしいんで
すごい勉強になりました
だから前のお医者さん…もすごかったんですけど
今回のお医者さんは説得力があったというか
なんかアトピーかまだ
どうかわからないらしいんですけど、原因が。
まずは現状のこの酷い…状態？
こことこことこことここね
酷い状況を治してから
またちょっと、こういうことがまたならないように
考えましょうって感じで
まあ現状、今の肌の状態を治すこと…と言われました
で、これが最強の保湿クリームで
こっちが多分ヒルドイド
1日2回しか使っちゃダメって言われたんで
これ多分めっちゃ強いやつです
いやー…苦しいねぇ…
痒いのまじで苦しい
気持ちいいからついつい掻くと
止まんなくなっちゃうから
苦しいってか…とてもつらい思いをしておりました
いやもう隙あれば塗ろ、まじで、本当に、
ふふふふんっ
ふんっ(パン)
ふふんっ(パンパン)
ふふふふんっ(パン)
ふんっふんっ
ふふんっふんっ
ふんふんっ
まあアトピーの可能性が出て来たっていうのと
やっぱ結局保湿ですね
保湿が大事です
頑張って保湿しまくって肌のレベルを上げてって
そっからアトピーをどうしよっかっていう話になってくるらしいです
見た目だけでもちょっと治したいなと思っております
いやーあと痒いのがやっぱ つらい。
早く完治できるように、頑張ります
じゃあなっ(控えめ)
[通常ED]
走るはじめん。
チャンネル登録よろしくネ!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!